The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Who's going to lecture?
Wow.
Nice.
Does lecture make sense?
One, two, three-- sort of.
OK.
Then I'm going to
have an easy job.
So any pointed questions?
Any specific pinpoints?
We talked about DFS, but DFS
and BFS are sort of related,
so I'm happy to take both.
AUDIENCE: The
classification of edges?
PROFESSOR: OK.
We're going to talk
about that for sure.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: I thought it was
funny that in undirected graphs,
you could have a backward--
or something like that.
PROFESSOR: You don't
have to give a radiance.
I will derive it.
OK So what edges do we have
in directed versus undirected.
OK.
What else?
Cool.
So I'm going to go through the
concepts in DFS really quickly.
And we're going
to focus on this.
Because it seems like this
is where the issues are.
I want this.
So what's a graph?
AUDIENCE: Interconnected notes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Fancy names.
Come on.
We had this in
the last workshop.
AUDIENCE: A set of
edges and vertices.
PROFESSOR: All right.
How do I draw my vertices?
AUDIENCE: Dots.
Circles.
PROFESSOR: Dots.
How do I draw my edges?
AUDIENCE: Dots.
Lines.
Oops.
PROFESSOR: Looks like a graph?
What kind of graph?
Directed.
Because there are arrows
and not straight up lines.
Right?
How do we store
graphs in Python?
Fancy name first and
then implementation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] list.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What's an adjacency
list in Python?
AUDIENCE: It just
shows what notes
are adjacent to other notes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what data
structure do we use?
What elementary python
data structure do we use?
AUDIENCE: A dictionary?
PROFESSOR: All right.
So an adjacency list is a
dictionary that keys our--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the keys are the vertices.
So on and so forth.
And what are the values?
AUDIENCE: The nodes?
Adjacent nodes?
PROFESSOR: OK.
A list of something.
So after our presentation,
is the object the one
that has edges
and the simplified
one that has vertices.
So suppose I want to
go for the simple one.
Where vertices do
I have in A's list?
AUDIENCE: B and G. Right?
PROFESSOR: B and G. Sounds good.
Right.
What vertices do I
have in B's list?
AUDIENCE: C.
PROFESSOR: Why do I not have A?
AUDIENCE: Because it's an
arrow, so it can't get to A.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the nodes that
I have in the list
are the nodes that are
reachable from that node.
I have an edge from B to C,
so C is reachable from B.
I do not have an
edge from B to A
because my edges are directed.
So A is not there.
OK.
Let's write a bit of pseudo-
So although it's Python,
let's say our graph is
represented by a class G. Let's
say in this class I
have a dictionary called
al, which has what we want.
If I want to get all the
vertices in the graph,
I want to write the method
that returns all the vertices.
What should it look like?
Just to make sure that we're
all getting the data structure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the keys are in the vertices.
Now, given the vertex,
I want its neighbors.
How do I write that?
AUDIENCE: You mean only the
vertices that it can go to?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Dictionary and that vertex.
PROFESSOR: So
return dictionary--
AUDIENCE: al bracket vertex v.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
OK.
So this makes sense
for everyone, right?
Let's start writing
DFS because no one
said they don't understand DFS.
So let's say we have
a DFS procedure.
And it gets a graph.
And it has to do DFS.
What do you need for DFS?
Starting points would be good.
Just like for DFS, right?
So how do we do DFS?
AUDIENCE: Start with
one node and then we
keep on following a path down
by picking the first vertex.
So like for A,
we'd start with A.
Then we'd pick the first
vertex in its list.
And then we pick the first
vertex in that one's list,
first vertex in that one's
list, until we run out.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So basically you start today.
And for every neighbor,
you recursively
do DFS on that neighbor.
Right?
So since this is
recursive, let's write it
in a recursive
manner, nice and easy.
So say DFS calls DFS
visit of g and s.
And let's say DFS
visit takes the graph,
takes the node that
we're visiting,
and how are we
implementing this?
AUDIENCE: Just
return [INAUDIBLE].
No.
It marks as visited.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Marking something as visited
is important to lead this.
So what's the main thing
that you do in DFS?
Iterate over the
neighbors and recurse.
Right?
So for n in g neighbors of v
called DFS visit of g and n.
So this is the basic idea.
It has some holes that we need
to fill because otherwise it
doesn't quite work.
This is going to
recurse forever,
which is not very good
if you have a time
limit that your
code needs to obey.
So how do I make it
not recurse forever?
AUDIENCE: Every time you visit,
you're about to visit a node,
check if you've
already visited it.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So we should keep
track of the nodes
that we've already visited
and not visit them again.
Right.
So you start with
A, go to B, go to C,
you'd better not go to A
again because you've already
been there.
So let's implement
that this way.
Let's make a new object
called DFS result that
is sort of that
drawer that you have
where you stick
everything in where
you don't have a good place.
So everything I do
not have a good place
to put it, you just
stick it in a drawer.
And then you can close
the drawing that be like,
it's clean.
Everything's clean.
So let's say DFS
result is that drawer.
Everything that they
need from now on,
we're just going
to stick in there.
So I have an object DFS result.
And we're going to figure
out what we put in it.
But at the beginning of DFS,
I'm going to create that.
So create the new object.
And then I'm going to
pass it onto to DFS visit.
So now we have a drawer where
we can put everything we want.
So let's keep track of the
visited information here.
How would I keep track
of what nodes I visited?
AUDIENCE: In a list?
PROFESSOR: In a list.
So if I do a list, it
turns out that in DFS,
and VFS, for that
matter, you check
if you visited a
node pretty often.
So it would be kind of slow.
So let's have a dictionary.
What are we going to
put in that dictionary?
AUDIENCE: The node [INAUDIBLE]
and listed [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we're going to have
a visited dictionary.
And then the keys are
going to be nodes.
And let's say we're only going
to put the nodes that we visit
in it so we don't
have to initialize it.
And the values are
going to be true.
Because if the node
is in the dictionary,
it means we visited it.
So for all the nodes
that are in there,
visited is going to be true.
Sorry.
OK.
So where do I fill this in?
Let's use it.
AUDIENCE: Four n and g
neighbors, set it to true.
But before that--
PROFESSOR: So here?
AUDIENCE: R not.
Um.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's say this.
Let's say these
are lines 1, 2, 3.
Line 1.5 or 2.5?
AUDIENCE: So at n 1.5, check
if v is in the dictionary.
PROFESSOR: Here?
OK.
If v in r dot visited, then--
AUDIENCE: Return.
Then 2.5, set r dot n to true.
You would only do it n times--
PROFESSOR: Wait.
So here you're saying say r
dot visited of n equals true?
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
Change the v in
v visited return,
change that into a loop.
Put that after the loop.
Put that into the loop.
And it's n visited
to the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: n in r dot visited--
we probably want not n, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
R dot visited is true
and then the DFS.
So will this achieve the thing
that I wanted at the beginning.
You start at A, you
go to B, you go to C,
and then you do not go to A?
Not quite.
AUDIENCE: We haven't
had our starting yet.
Yeah.
We could add V at the
beginning and check at the end.
Because that's only
the visited, right?
PROFESSOR: So I think I
like Christian's suggestion.
r dot visited of v is true.
And then we can
remove it from here.
AUDIENCE: It has
to be [INAUDIBLE]
because the other
case is going to cover
for if you visited again.
But the first time it's being
called, it's not checking--
PROFESSOR: Well you mean
the first time here?
AUDIENCE: The first
call that's being made,
and the recursive
call, it's going
to be as if it's not
into the visited node.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But this is at the beginning.
Right?
So this calls DFS visit
to the starting node.
Do we care?
So I think this should work.
It's not the only way to write
it, but it's reasonably clean.
It's easy to reason
about, and it works.
Does it make sense to everyone?
OK.
We're going to change
things a little bit.
So instead of using
visited, we're
going to keep track for
every node of its parent.
So the node that
we visited from.
So we're not going to
use visited anymore.
Instead we're going
to use parent of v
is going to be some other node.
So what I want is
for this graph,
I said I'm going to go from
A to B, and then from B to C.
So I want the parent of B to be
A, and the parent of C to be B.
Make sense for everyone?
So what's the parent of A?
AUDIENCE: None.
PROFESSOR: None's a
good value, right?
There's no parent.
OK.
So how would I modify
this code to write that?
AUDIENCE: Stick a line
in 2.75 and establish 3b
as the parent of n.
PROFESSOR: So r dot parent?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, of n is v.
PROFESSOR: Of n is v. Good.
And I don't have
visited anymore,
so this line is
going to blow up.
So what do I do instead?
AUDIENCE: Oh.
It doesn't have a parent?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So if it doesn't have a
parent, we didn't visit it.
So the parents works
just like visited,
except the values are
not going to be all true.
They're going to be
something a bit more useful.
AUDIENCE: We can't test for
none because the first one has
a value of none.
PROFESSOR: But they're
not testing for none,
we're saying is it in
the dictionary or not?
AUDIENCE: Oh.
OK.
PROFESSOR: That's a good point.
You could be testing for none.
That wouldn't work.
So you have to write
the check like this.
And we're going to erase
this because otherwise, it's
going to throw an exception.
And what else do we need?
There's one missing parent.
AUDIENCE: Inverse form?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Where do I say that?
AUDIENCE: In DFS.
PROFESSOR: OK.
One, two, three, which line?
1.5, 2.5, 3.5?
AUDIENCE: 2.5.
PROFESSOR: 2.5.
All right, so here.
What do I write?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Parent of s is none.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So r dot parent s is none.
So now this works.
Right?
Any questions so far?
Nope.
Basic DFS works.
Everyone's happy with it?
Let's try to track it
for this graph here.
And you're going to be in
a better position than me
because I'm not sure I
can see the graph all
the way from here.
Almost.
So let's have the parents or
the parent's dictionary here.
And here, let's write the call
structure as it will happen.
So where do I start?
DFS of A, right?
DFS of A. And this is
going to call DFS visit A.
What are A's neighbors?
AUDIENCE: b and g.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
Is b in parents?
What's in parents,
at this point?
AUDIENCE: Just a.
Oh.
PROFESSOR: A is none.
Good.
Excellent.
So B is not in parents,
so what am I going to do?
And it's the parents in visited.
Right?
What's B's parents?
AUDIENCE: A.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I'm going to call DFS
visit of B. These children.
C. Is C parents?
No?
What happens?
Feel free to take over.
When you get it, feel
free to start talking,
and I can just write.
AUDIENCE: Of C.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What else?
PROFESSOR: C's
parent is B. So I'm
in B. The only child is
C. C is not in parents.
C gets in parent.
C's parent is B. Call DFS visit
of C, what are C's children?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] and d.
PROFESSOR: So we're wondering
about the order, right?
Let's assume that in
the adjacency list,
all the nodes are in
alphabetical order.
So I'm going to have
A, D, and F. OK.
Is A in parents?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Is D in parents?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: So what happens?
AUDIENCE: Parents visit
D. D's parent is C.
PROFESSOR: D's neighbors?
AUDIENCE: E and F.
PROFESSOR: E is in the-- no.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Cool.
Does E have any children?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: So I'm done.
I get out of it, right?
Is F in parents?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: F's parent is?
Cool.
F doesn't have any children.
Right?
So I get out of this DFS visit.
I'm done with F. So I
get out of this visit.
And I get back to this one.
I'm done with D, and I'm
at F. Is F in parents?
OK.
So what kind of edge is C to F?
AUDIENCE: Forward.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So forward maybe tree.
Let's start with the easy ones.
So now we've gone forward
with AB, BC, CD, DE, and DF.
What kind of edges
are these ones?
Tree edges.
Does anyone know why
they're called tree edges?
So if you look at the parent
pointers that they have there,
they're going to end
up defining a tree.
And the tree is, the
tree shows the order
in which DFS looked
at the notes.
So let me erase this and
draw the tree for DFS
that we had so far.
So we started at A, then we went
to B. Then we went to C, then
we went to D, E, F. So this is
all part of the DFS tree.You
can see that for
all these nodes,
their parent pointers
point the right way.
So if you have parent
pointers for every node,
this is going to
give you a tree.
So these are tree edges because
they're part of this tree.
So now we have this
edge from C to F.
And this is what kind of edge?
Forward edge.
Why is it a forward edge?
AUDIENCE: Somewhere
up higher in the tree
is trying to get somewhere
lower on the tree.
It's going forward in time.
PROFESSOR: So it's going
from a node in the tree
to a node's child in the tree.
Sorry, not child.
Descendant.
So F is strictly
under C. So yeah.
It takes us forward in time.
It's a shortcut in the tree.
So that's why it's
a forward edge.
So we now have two
types of edges so far.
Tree edges and forward edges.
AUDIENCE: So tree
edges [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So the tree edges are the
ones that DFS follows.
All of these are tree edges.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So like
an edge from B to C,
why can't that be
a forward edge?
Because technically it's
not a shortcut, right?
But it's saying it's
pointing to the children,
but it only has one child.
PROFESSOR: Because that's
the edge that DFS took.
So the edges that we
actually follow in DFS
have a special name,
and they're tree edges.
So first off, the
most important edges
are the edges that
make up your DFS tree.
And that's why those
are tree edges.
We don't even look
at the other types.
If you have an edge and DFS
followed it, it's a tree edge.
Done.
So these are all tree edges.
We don't care about
the other definitions.
So don't be ashamed to
ask questions about this
because this is
hard to understand.
It's an issue we're
trying to clarify here.
So the point, why we're
doing that example,
is to figure this out.
So please do ask your questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is it edges that
are followed at any point
during the search process?
I guess they're edges
that never get touched.
Right?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So when I'm at C, and
I look at this edge,
F is already in parents.
So this edge is not going
to be followed by DFS.
There are some
other types of edges
that will not be followed.
And we'll get to that by
the time DFS completes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You mean that
like G to C is not--
PROFESSOR: You're
ruining my example, man.
I'm supposed to ask
you that later on.
So let's let go through it and
see what kind of edge it is.
You're right, but let's
pretend we don't know that.
And we'll see as
we follow the DFS.
OK.
So yep.
That one's a forward edge.
We'll deal with it later.
We're here.
We decided that C to
F is a forward edge.
F is already in parents.
So we're going to
return from DFS visit
C. We're in DFS visit
V. We're done with C.
Do we have anything
else to do here?
So we go up to A. We're done
with B. And we look at G. A
to G. Is G in parents?
No.
So we're going to call it.
So A, B. DFS visit G.
What are G's neighbors?
AUDIENCE: C.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So is C in parents?
Actually I was wrong.
Sorry.
So C is in parents, so
we're not going to visit it.
So let's see how the tree
looks like at this point.
So it looks like this.
Is C a child of G?
So I'm wondering about this edge
that we chose not to follow.
We followed A to G so we know
this is actually the edge.
So from this edge, G to C, I'm
wondering what kind of edge
it is.
So C is not G's child, right?
So another forward edge.
Sorry.
I got confused
earlier because they
look the same in a drawing.
So it's not a forward edge,
then it's a cross edge.
There's one more
edge that we haven't
talked about because it was
too early in the search.
And that edge is from C
to A. So if you remember
there, we were in DFS visit
C. And the first thing we did
was we looked at A, we said,
hey it's already in parents,
so we're not going to visit it.
So DFS did not follow
the edge C to A.
That edge looks like this.
What kind of edge is it?
Back edge.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
So it has to be direct
descendant in order
to be a forward edge?
Because they are related
through A, right?
C and G?
PROFESSOR: So you have to look
and which direction does it go?
Does it go down the
tree or up the tree?
AUDIENCE: It's going down if you
consider G to C. From G to C,
so it's a cross edge.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But is C G's descendant?
AUDIENCE: No.
But they are related.
PROFESSOR: They're
related, but they're just
related because
they're in the tree.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it's only
directly descendants?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So DFS puts together a tree.
A forward edge is a
shortcut in that tree.
It lets you go
forward in the VFS.
A backward edge points
to a parent in the tree,
so it lets you go back in time.
A cross edge takes you from
one point to another point.
And it's not a forward
edge, not a backward edge.
So it takes you in a
whole different world.
So C, A, G, has-- A,
G is the sub-tree,
and then this guy's
this other sub-tree,
and they're different
little worlds.
And this edge goes
from one to the other.
So the algorithm to decide what
kind of an edge it is, let's
put it together.
Which edge do we look at, which
type do we think about first?
Tree edge.
So DFS followed the edge.
It's a tree edge.
So we have tree edges.
What do we do next?
So say we have an edge from
u to v. If DFS follows it,
it's a tree edge.
If not, then what
question do I ask myself?
AUDIENCE: It could be
one of three edges then,
back, forward, or cross.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's try to write
a simple algorithm
so that if I ask
you this on a quiz,
you can decide which is which.
AUDIENCE: So I think
that you look forward
if u is the parent of v.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So if u is a parent of v--
well, let's say ascendant.
It's not just the
direct parent, but this
is the right intuition.
Then what kind of edge is it?
AUDIENCE: Then it's
the forward edge.
PROFESSOR: So the edge is from
u to v. If u is a parent of v,
forward edge.
Good.
Otherwise?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Then?
AUDIENCE: Then backward edge.
Else cross edge.
PROFESSOR: Does this make sense?
So these are the
four types of edges.
DFS takes the edge,
it's a forward edge.
If not, we draw the DFS tree.
And we see does
the edge go forward
in the tree, forward edge.
Does it go backward,
backward edge.
Does it grow between completely
unrelated nodes, cross edge.
OK.
Now let me ask another question.
Let's suppose we do
this DFS thing again,
but let's suppose we do
it on an undirected graph.
What types of edges do I have?
Anyone remember off
the top of their heads?
Don't think so, right?
So let's do it and find out.
So let me see where
do I get some room.
Here.
Let's write the tree
that's we're going to go.
So let's do a VFS of this
quickly and write the tree.
So we start at A, then what?
Then?
D. E.
AUDIENCE: And go back to
D. It could go from C to A.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we have C to A. What
kind of edge is this?
AUDIENCE: Backward edge.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we still have tree edges
for sure and backward edges.
AUDIENCE: How do
you get from C to A?
PROFESSOR: This was supposed
to happen way before.
So we went A, B, C, and
then when we were at C, oh.
Sorry.
My bad.
So we went from A to
B, B to C, and then A
was the first thing
in C's adjacency list.
So we saw this back edge.
So C to D, D to E, D to F.
AUDIENCE: E to F?
Or F to C?
PROFESSOR: And then F to C.
So what kind of edge is this?
AUDIENCE: Backward.
PROFESSOR: So none
of these guys.
And then we're all the
way back at A, right?
A to-- oh.
Sorry.
No we're not done.
So C to D, D to E, D to F, then
we're back at C. And C to G.
AUDIENCE: There's supposed
to be a line between C and F?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
I guess I can't copy.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
Now it's right.
Thank you.
OK.
So what am I missing?
Edge from C to G.
What kind of edge?
AUDIENCE: C and G?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we have tree edges and
we have backward edges.
What do we not have?
Forward edges and
cross edges, right?
AUDIENCE: You need one from
A to G. A and G are related.
PROFESSOR: What edge is this?
Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You never add
those, though, right?
You just see that A was in the
parent's list, and be like, OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So for all the edges
that are not tree edges,
DFS doesn't actually
follow them.
We just care about them
because other algorithms
care about them.
They let you compute
fancy things on the graph.
OK.
So are we good with the types?
So why can't I have
a forward edge?
So there are two types
of edges I can't have,
cross edges and forward edges.
Why can't I have a forward edge?
On an undirected graph?
So in order to have
a forward edge,
I would have to go C, D, F.
And then not follow this edge.
I mean not see this edge here.
Right?
If this edge would
be undirected,
I would say, hey, it goes from
F to C. It's a background edge.
So I would have seen this edge
when I would have been in C.
So I'm comparing this
tree with this tree,
and trying to figure out
why they're different.
How does a forward
edge look like?
You have a node u, then you
have some more tree stuff.
And from here, you got to v.
And then when you're at v,
you didn't see the edge.
Right?
Because if you
would have seen it,
it would have been
a background edge.
So you can only see the
edge from u to v later on.
So this is tree edges,
a bunch of tree edges,
and this is a forward edge.
In an undirected
graph, this never
happens because
when you're at v,
you're going to see the edge.
And you're going to mark
it as a backward edge.
So forward edges
can ever happen.
Yes?
No?
Is everyone happy?
So cross edges.
Why can't they happen?
A cross edge can never
happen because in order
for a cross edge to happen,
I would have to go A, B, C,
visit C's children, then go
up and go somewhere else.
And then see this edge.
But, hey, when I was at C,
why didn't I see this edge?
Why did I only see it later?
If it's an undirected graph,
I would see this edge here
and it would be a forward edge.
Sorry.
A tree edge, because
that would take it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is it just
when you're-- is it just
because it's the way you
traverse in DFS or would it
apply generally to VFS as well?
PROFESSOR: VFS doesn't
have forward and backward.
Yeah.
VFS is completely different.
So these are all DFS
terms, purely DFS.
OK.
So no forward edges,
no cross edges.
And if you forget which
ones you can and can't have,
now you know how to reason
about it quickly and remember.
Yes?
OK.
So this is DFS.
Are we all happy with DFS?
Let's talk about
topological sorting then.
Because it's really useful.
It's one of the few algorithms
that is really useful
and that you might have
to write yourself later.
So suppose these are classes.
So let's get back to
this oriented thing
and suppose these are classes.
And the edges show
prerequisites.
So A is a prerequisite
of B. Like say A is 601
and B is 6006.
And you have to take 601
before you take 6006.
Otherwise you will cry during
programming assignments.
So what we want
to do is these are
all the classes you
need to graduate.
We need to come up with an
order in which you can take them
so that when you take a class,
you took all the prerequisites.
So you don't cry while
you're taking that class.
How do we do that?
And let's use this
graph as an example.
AUDIENCE: Use a directed
graph that's acyclic?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Is this graph acyclic?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what then?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So if the
graph has a cycle,
you can't solve the problem.
It has no solution.
AUDIENCE: It's like
those cardboard boxes
that [INAUDIBLE].
It's really annoying.
PROFESSOR: I don't know
the cardboard box problem.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You know those cardboard
boxes with the four flaps
when you close them, and
they close like-- Yeah.
Those are so annoying.
That's just what
this reminds me of.
That's all.
Continue.
PROFESSOR: There's
a cycle there,
so you can't just
put them in an order.
Right?
You have to violate the
repeating variance somehow.
And you do that by
twisting the edges.
So if we had classes A, B, C,
you cannot take them in any
order.
Right?
If you take A first, you would
need C. If you take B first,
you would need A. If you take
C first, you would need B.
So you can't start
with any of them.
So if you have a
cycle in a graph,
it's not a dependency graph.
You can't compute dependencies.
So topological sorts only
works on cyclic graphs.
So acyclic graph.
And what else?
So a dependency graph is
a special kind of graph.
And I'm looking for
three fancy words.
You already have two.
So we have acyclic
and we have graph.
Directed.
So you have to
have a directed, so
that you know which
class goes first.
Needs to be acyclic,
otherwise there's no solution.
Needs to be a graph,
because that's
what we're talking about.
So the shortening
for this is a DAG.
OK.
How do you compute an order?
So say we remove that edge.
How do we compute an order?
AUDIENCE: You run DFS and
then print out the reverse.
PROFESSOR: And then
print out the reverse?
AUDIENCE: Of your final output.
PROFESSOR: Which is?
AUDIENCE: Your final output?
You want me to do it on a graph?
PROFESSOR: You can tell me
how to change the codes, too.
So I'm not sure what-- you said
print the reverse of something,
but what's that thing?
AUDIENCE: So I go
down a path, right,
until you've hit
all the nodes, then
basically you start
from the last node
you visited and print
out the reverse of that.
Go back to the first node.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you're saying I go
A, B, C, D, E, and then
I print E, D, C, B, A?
AUDIENCE: No.
Because that wouldn't
hit all the nodes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
He's on the right track, by
the way, so that's why we're--
AUDIENCE: You go
A, B, C, D, E, F,
G, and you print G,
F, E, D, C, B, A.
PROFESSOR: OK so we print
them in the reverse.
So you're printing them in
the order in which you're
done with them after DFS?
No.
You're printing them
in the reverse order
of the order which
you visited them?
So you visited A,
B, C, D, E, F, G,
so you're saying print
G, F, E, D, C, B, A.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Because in lecture
wasn't it flipped,
so if an arrow points from
A to B then A depends on B.
And we're looking at
the other way around.
In lecture, based
on the graph you
gave, if the arrow goes from
A to B, then A depends on B.
PROFESSOR: If the arrow
goes from A to B, then what?
AUDIENCE: If you're saying A
is a prerequisite for B and G,
then we just sweep from
left to right and say,
I have to do this.
And then those two.
PROFESSOR: No.
They have to--
AUDIENCE: It's the order that--
because when you're doing DFS,
you recurse.
It's the order that they
finished the recurse.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You have the right answer.
I'm just trying to build
out the annotation for it.
I'm pretty sure this
is the right way.
I can look at this,
but I can't promise you
that this is the right
way because I coded it
and it works.
So no.
This is the right way.
Yes.
This is the right way
to represent them.
So forward edge
means B depends on A.
OK.
So let's figure
out how we do this.
Let's do this in
pseudo-code and then build
the intuition for it.
So you said reverse of
the finishing times.
So let's build a list
that has all the nodes
in the order of their
finishing times.
So let's build a list finished
that is empty at first.
Then I'm going to add
all the nodes in the list
as I'm done with them.
And then I'll reverse the list.
Where do I add
nodes to the list?
AUDIENCE: In the check.
Line 2.75.
PROFESSOR: Not quite.
So line 4.
So I'm adding them in the order
in which I'm done with them.
So when I'm about to
leave a node completely,
I'll add it to that list.
Which node?
What's the name?
AUDIENCE: V.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And then where can
I reverse the list?
AUDIENCE: Line 4 of the first--
PROFESSOR: OK.
How would I do this?
r dot finished dot reverse.
Like this?
AUDIENCE: I think
that's OK in Python.
PROFESSOR: I think so, too.
So this will give me
a topological sort.
Let's figure out why
this works intuitively.
Yes?
So while we're building
the topological sort,
while we're building the
inverse of the final list.
So the first thing
that we put in the list
is the last class
we're going to take.
So as I go forward
in this graph,
my VFS is going to go A, B, C,
D, E. There's nothing after E.
And it's done with E.
So this means there is no class
that depends on E. Otherwise,
DFS would keep recursing.
So E is the last class I take.
If I take this last, there's
definitely no dependencies
that I'm violating.
All right?
So it's safe to start with E.
Now I'm out of E, I'm back to D.
I go from D to F, I print that.
Let's not worry about
this for a little bit.
And let's go back
to D. When DFS comes
back, it's going
to print D. So I
know that by the
time DFS is out,
I printed all the classes
that depend on D. Right?
So when I'm at D,
whenever I have forward
edges that I
haven't visited yet,
I will call DFS visit on them.
DFS visit returns before
I can get out of D.
So all the edges that depend
on D have been printed.
Sorry.
All the nodes that depend
on D have been printed.
So when I get out of D, I
know that all the nodes that
depend on D have
been printed, so it's
safe to print D.
This is the intuition
behind topological sort.
So you can build sort of an
induction proof based on this.
So whenever I'm here, I
assume that all the nodes
that I have forward edges to
are somewhere in my results.
So I can include my nodes.
So this means that whenever
you put a node here,
all the nodes that have
forward edges to this node
have already been output.
So this means that no
dependency relationships
are going to be violated.
OK.
Let's keep building
this and see the result.
So D, E, F, we get
out of B. We get out
of C. What do we do here?
Print C, right?
What classes depend on C?
D, E, and F. I had
a tree edge to D.
I had DFS visit here, so I
know that all the classes that
depend on C because they
depend on D have been output.
And then I have a
forward edge on F.
So I didn't recurse
from C to F, but I
know that has been
covered somewhere.
Right?
Forward edge means that
I've already seen it in DFS,
and that I've already
returned from it.
So it has already been printed.
So I'm going to write this.
Now I get out of C. I get out of
B. I go into G. I get out of B,
and I go into A. And I go
out of A, and I print it.
OK.
So I have tree edges
that I can handle.
So these are all tree edges.
And the reason that topological
sorting works on tree edges
is that I call DFS
visit on the tree edge,
and I know it returns
by the time I return.
So I know that
whatever's underneath
that tree has
already been printed.
I have forward edges that
will just take me forward
in the DFS.
So I know that by the
time I return from a node,
I've already returned
from all the nodes
that I have forward
edges to because they're
lower in the tree.
Right?
Forward edges work like this.
So by the time
I'm out of C, I've
definitely printed F. Now I have
this cross edge from G to C.
A cross edge means that there
is no direct relationship here,
but I've already visited C. If
there's no direct relationship,
it means that for sure
I'm done visiting C
and I've returned so
that I can get to G.
So there's some common
parent between C and G.
I'm already done with C, and
I've returned to that parent.
And then I went to G.
So all the nodes that are
pointed to my cross edges
have also been printed
in topological sort.
OK.
Now what about back edges?
What if I had a back edge?
What if I had this back
edge between C and A?
What happens then?
If I had a back edge, then that
would break topological sort.
Right?
Because this is
saying that hey, you
should print A
before you print C.
But I know that I'm going
to come out of C way
before I have a chance
to come out of A.
So if I have a back edge,
topological sort doesn't work.
When do I have a back edge?
When I have a cycle.
So this is why I don't
care about back edges.
Back edges [INAUDIBLE] cycles.
So back edge means I
have a path forward.
And I have a path backward.
That does a cycle.
OK.
There's an awful
lot of silence here.
Does everything makes sense or?
OK.
Any questions?
Nope?
Everyone's happy?
So you don't need to
reason about this formally.
Just remember the intuition that
the reason we're printing them
in this order is
the first thing you
print is the last class
you're going to take.
Because for sure there are
no dependencies left on it,
otherwise DFS would
keep recursing.
And then there's that recursive
structure that makes this work.
OK.
Cool.